in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
americans
is far greater than what divides us
today one of congressman john lewis's
greatest victories on capitol hill
was passing the bill that established
the smithsonian national museum of
african-american history
and culture that's in washington d.c
lewis was known as the godfather
of that museum after fighting for its
creation for decades
chip reed shows us how lewis's legacy
and advocacy is entwined
with we its not want our freedom
gradually
but we want to be free now at just 23
years old budding civil rights icon john
lewis delivered a historic speech during
the 1963 march on washington
about five decades later he would be
back on the national mall
this time as congressman john lewis to
give a speech at the opening
of the smithsonian national museum of
african american history and culture
this place is more than a building it is
a dream come true
lewis introduced 13 different bills
starting
in the 1980s to create the museum he was
met with opposition
at every point along the way once we
approve this museum
we will be called upon by other minority
groups and they will be justified in
doing so
to provide museums for their particular
groups
but lewis never gave up spending nearly
15 years pushing
and in 2003 he was there when president
bush
signed legislation to make it a reality
the museum opened in 2016 about 28 years
after lewis first proposed it our gail
king asked him what it was like to walk
through the museum's doors
for the first time i've been holding
back tears
because so many of the exhibits so many
of this museum remind me of the struggle
lonnie bunch is the head of the
smithsonian institution
and oversees its 19 museums he was the
first director
of this one john lewis felt that history
was
a valuable tool to help people live
their lives
that people needed to understand and
draw inspiration
from the past the eight-story museum is
a reflection of 400 years of
african-american history
everything from slavery struggle and
triumph
to black culture entertainment and
achievement
he wanted to make sure that 20 50 100
years from now
these stories of our rich culture would
be remembered
lewis did not just help imagine and
create the museum he himself
is part of the history displayed within
its walls
good trouble as lewis called it fighting
for justice and equality despite
arrests and police beatings in the last
weeks of the freedom fighter's life came
the death of george floyd and nationwide
protests against police brutality
hundreds of demonstrators swarmed the
museum
in one of his final interviews last
month with cbs
this morning lewis applauded the
protesters
there's another step down a very very
long road
toward freedom
justice for all humankind
and as that road is traveled by a new
generation
lewis's legacy will live on in the
museum
he helped build it is my hope
that each and every person who visit
this beautiful museum will walk away
deeply inspired the museum is currently
closed due to the corona virus but
interim director spencer crew told us it
will
open as soon as it is safe he also
encourages people to go to the museum's
website to learn
all about the role that african
americans have played in shaping
this great nation gail
i think that's a really good idea chip
talk about filling me up that's what you
just did
john lewis when you think about him life
well lived job well
done the epitome of goodness was
fighting for justice till the very until
his body gave out thank you so much chip
it was really really terrific we'll be
right back